(はじめ)時に、てつや！
(はじめ)デスソースというものを知っているか?
(はじめ)ね、どっかいっちゃったんだけど探そう
（はじめ）デスソースが欲しいの　（てつや）いや絶対に嫌
（はじめ）デスソースが欲しいの　本当探そう、あれがないと今日の企画ほんとうにもう
（てつや）ええぇぇぇ
(はじめ）よぉぉぉし　ｷﾀｧｧｧｧｧｧ
（はじめ）よおし　見つかりましたぁ
久しぶりにyoutuberが家に来ました
こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーと、
こんにちわ！ｗはじめしゃちょーとｗ、
こんｗちわ！はじめしゃちょーｗと
い゛ああ
はい、とういうわけで
今日はですね
皆さん、YouTuberといえばまあデスソースですよね。
ﾃﾞﾍﾞキっ！
ﾝーーﾅﾝﾏｱﾏｱﾏｱﾏｱ
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｯ!!!
ほら！ほら
ちょびっと口につけるだけでも
スゴイ大ダメージというか、
辛すぎて、
どうしようもないことになってしまうという
このデスソースが、ございます。
ｹﾞﾎｯ
で今回まあデスソースを使って、
その...ちょっとあることをしようと思いまして
こんなに辛いから
使い道がね、
食べるというほかにないと思います。
食べる以外の使い方ができないかと思ったときに
私は今回、デスソースで、
世の中ね、食べることがすべてじゃありませんからね!
痛っ！
待って、大けがした
何で？何の素材で？
あーヤバイ、痛
ﾝｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｯ!!!ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はいというわけで今回の動画はここまでです...。
バイバ~イ
Fisc○er'風のED
絶対そこ狙いますからね
あぁ↑？
んん～ん↑♪
ｯﾊﾊｯﾊwwww
これなんか調べたんですけど、
へ～
飛距離かなぁ？
飛距離なのかなぁ？
70フィート飛ぶ?
どれくらいなのかなぁ？
デスソースで水鉄砲するにしても、
デスソースはドロドロなんですよね、ソースですから
なんでちょっと薄めて、
水鉄砲で打てるぐらいの薄さにして、
てつやと打ち合ってね、
一応ルールとしては、
口を開けっ放し
ぇう～わ～　バカだこの人！
口を開けっ放しにして、
口の中が、まぁ狙いというか
こうほんとに正面でかわしながら、
敵の口を狙うという
戦いになります
では早速やっていこうと思う！
では行こう！
では、
（うわ！メッチャ辛れぇ！！！）
（てつや）：ンニャー！もう意味わかんないよ！こんなん
で一応、作戦としては、
この中に、デスソースを入れて、液体状のデスソースを作って、ここで水を補充して、てつやと撃ち合います。
（はじめ）うああああもうコレほんとに、匂いが凄い！
※デスソースに触れたときは注意してね！
皮膚が弱い人は痛くかゆくなります！！
（はじめ）ｵｳｪ、ｹﾞﾎｯｹﾞﾎｯ
（はじめ）ｹﾞﾎｳｯｹﾞﾎｹﾞﾎｳｯ！
（てつや）う”う”う”う”
（てつや）ｹﾞｴﾎｯ!  ｳ"ｳ"ｴｪｯﾎｳ　ｹﾞｯﾎｳ!
ｳｳｱｧｧｯﾎﾝﾝｯ！
ホントにヤバイね！
（てつや）ここダメだ
ﾌｴｪｪｯｯﾎｵｵｫﾝｯ↗!
デスソースWATER in
あのたぶん目に入ると一発で失明するので、
水中ゴーグルをつけてやります
はｗｗちょｗえｗｗ
なんでこんなにブサイクなんだろう
これでどっちが上か下かになるからね
結構勝負が決まってくると思います
最初はグー！ジャンケンポン！
おおっシャア！
上!（キリっ
OK、わかりゃした－
Battle Start!!!!!!
（てつや）あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛
※しばらく二人のこの表情をお楽しみください
いくぜ！
Battle Start!!!!!
※しばらく二人の表情をお楽しみ下さい
（はじめ）う”え”ｯｯﾎ　ｳ”ｱ”ｯﾎ
（はじめ）ﾌｱｱｱｱﾝﾎﾝ”!!　（てつや）ｹﾞｯﾎ　ｳ"ｴ
次はラスト勝負です！
今僕が一本取ってるんで、
ここで、てつやが、勝たないと、
俺の勝ち
（はじめ）う”え”っ
（二人で）OPEN　THE　MOUTH!
（はじめ）あ”ぁ”～～
（てつや）ふんッ　ふんッ　ふんッ
（てつや）よっしゃぁぁｗｗｗ
（てつや）ふぉっほっほほっほ
～♪（沖縄風の音楽）
ふぉっほほっほっほほ
（何かをたたく音）
っはっはっっはｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ